so you you have the perspective I think
that people from your country from lots
of countries have here
that this country is better off than a
lot of the people who are native to it
will not allow for some reason they have
to on it I I mean when I talk to
immigrants that is one thing they do not
like about the left that they're always
down on this country we're irredeemable
and we're racist and everything is
looked through stained glasses
and they're like you know ask them why
they came here and they will tell you
Ron DeSantis put me on a plane
you know when I see how many of the
young people like me want to give
socialism and I and sometimes Marcus
Marxism a try I think Andrew Sullivan
wrote a great column on it he said Marx
Karl Marx the most assigned Economist
yes at the top schools the third most
taught book and Marx was a huge
to me someone who comes from the Soviet
Union is mind-boggling and you were
talking earlier about why this woke
ideology is so dangerous to the West it
is because people in other parts of the
world are not teaching their young
children to hate their own country
and if you if you continue to do this
how is how is the West going to do in
the Battle of civilizations because
that's what we're in right the Chinese
want to thrive the Russians want to
thrive and they're teaching their
children to be strong to be confident to
go out there to learn science instead of
you know equity and diversity
it doesn't work very well if it's built
on diversity instead of math so that
[Applause]
absolutely well I think it's a problem
by the way that is another trans
partisan thing because you see this on
the right a lot now with people with
Victor Orban